non si parla d'altro, ma non abbastanza.
Giorgia Meloni e lis line,
Antonio taiani, Carlo calenda
si candidano come capolista al Parlamento europeo, cioè
al luogo in cui
si prendono le
decisioni che contano. ma non ci andranno,
lo sanno loro,
lo sappiamo noi. Chi ci andrà al loro posto?
i primi dei non eletti,
vale a dire quelli che hanno preso meno voti.
e se hanno preso meno voti è perché
a volte sono sconosciuti AI più e evidentemente
anche il loro partito non li ha spinti granché.
un falso che accettiamo da anni senza batterciglio.
rivediamo i nomi.
2019, matteo Salvini è ministro dell'interno,
si candida in
tutte le circoscrizioni e solo nel Nord ovest
prende 696.000 preferenze.
ma Bruxelles?
al suo posto VA Marco campo menosi con solo 17.700
preferenze. fa lo stesso
Giorgia Meloni che dal leader
di Fratelli d'Italia
si candida in
tutte le circoscrizioni e solo nel Nord ovest
prende 92.850 voti.
anche qui al suo posto a Bruxelles VA Pietro fiocchi,
9300 preferenze
da presidente del consiglio. Berlusconi si
in Europa Ben 3 volte.
e poi c'è una lunga lista di ministri, Gianni alemanno,
Maurizio gasparri,
altero matteoli, Umberto Bossi,
Ignazio La Russa e Maurizio lupi.
e i leader di partito Oliviero di liberto, Marco follini,
clemente mastella,
Alfonso pecoraro scagno, achille occhietto,
Antonio Di Pietro.
tutti eletti, ma al loro posto a Bruxelles
ci sono andati i meno votati.
questo succede solo in Italia,
in tutti gli altri grandi paesi membri
i partiti presentano delle.
liste bloccate e che non è bello per la democrazia,
ma dentro ci mettono
i candidati con le competenze specifiche dei settori
di cui poi andranno ad occuparsi.
anche perché queste sono le elezioni europee più
importanti degli ultimi trent'anni,
dove si decide il futuro dell'europa
e a cascata quello dei singoli paesi.
allora, visto che le civette staranno a casa,
facciamo noi un salto di
responsabilità
votando direttamente gli altri nomi della lista.